the americas
home to millions of species of animal
who clash in savage battles of survival
but what happens when the new world's
most ruthless killers
turn against each other
animals fight tooth and claw against
their own kin
to win food
territory
and rights to the bloodline
in the wild badlands of the americas
there are no rules
this
is animal fight night
one of america's most iconic beasts
the grizzly bear
heavyweight champions of animal fight
night
[Music]
the only thing that scares a grizzly
is another grizzly
[Music]
they can charge at over 30 miles per
hour and bite with enough force to crush
a bowling ball
their strength and speed is thanks to a
1 000 pound body packed with muscle
concentrated in their shoulders hump
and buttocks
one source of their strength
is salmon
grizzlies can eat 40 a day
that's 100 000 calories
male bears are twice the size of females
but females need to catch more fish
to feed their young
and keep themselves
fighting fit
forty percent of bear cubs don't reach
adulthood
often falling prey to mountain lions
wolves or even adult male grizzlies
so females are ferocious when they're
protecting their cubs
[Music]
this mama bear
shows her cubs how to fish
[Music]
they learn by mimicking her
she dives in
but accidentally runs into another bear
in the confusion a rival female steals
her fish
mama bear is furious
and attacks
three-inch claws are as long as human
fingers
twice as long as the claws on her hind
paws
her swipe could shred skin
but thick fur protects the bear's body
the skin around her neck is 20 times
thicker than a human's
the rival female has given the fish to
her own cubs
mama won't stand for it
but she's bitten off more than she can
chew
she can't win
so backs down
the rival cubs eat their salmon dinner
while mama bear returns to her young
empty-handed
luckily there are plenty more fish in
the sea
and many more fights
in the americas
our next contender proves you don't have
to be big
to be a psychotic killing machine
because one of the top killers of
starlings
is other starlings
their weapons of choice beaks and claws
aimed right at the brain
[Music]
breeding season
and a male starling needs a nest to
attract a female
[Music]
this proud homeowner scored a piece of
prime real estate
and that got him the girl
but in starling world competition for
males is intense
rival females want to take her place
and they're willing to kill for it
immediately a threat
the husband is building a nest for eggs
he leaves to find raw materials
a female intruder seizes the moment
she flies in to find the wife home alone
[Music]
but the wife won't give in without a
fight
far away the husband has no idea his
home is under attack
they tried to pin each other down using
their claws
she struggles on
the invader uses her deadly weapon
going for the kill
aiming through the eye
for her brain
the husband returns to a shocking scene
[Music]
he freezes
they're exhausted
many bird species
males act as bystanders when females
fight
[Music]
but not starlings
[Music]
he intervenes
not to help his wife
but to stop her fighting
so he can have two wives
they take it outside
the wife isn't sharing her home or man
with anyone
10 of starling deaths are caused by
fights over nests
[Music]
the husband tries again
[Music]
it's getting too complicated for the
intruder
the wife has protected her home whether
the husband likes it or not
if they can keep it safe
the couple will have several fledglings
but the sky is filled with rival
starlings
this mating season
is far from over
the seasons don't get longer than in the
canadian arctic here only the hard
endure
and they don't come harder
than the musk ox
ice age survivors
muskox shared this land with woolly
mammoth
they weigh over 800 pounds
and live in small nomadic herds
these ancient warriors get along just
fine for most of the year
until
it's time to mate
when male horns become
a deadly weapon
and muskox become the battering rams of
the animal kingdom
this six-year-old bull was pushed out of
his herd by its dominant male
and now wanders the tundra alone
[Music]
picking up the musky scent of a bull
from another herd
he spots his target
the big chief
eight years old the chief is bigger but
size isn't everything
if the youngster can oust him
he'll win a harem of eight cows
it's a battle that kills one in ten
but it's worth a shot to continue his
bloodline
the raging bull approaches the big chief
the big chief tilts his head
showing off his horns
but his rival isn't intimidated
they swing their heads back and forth
this is a clear statement
it's fight time
the bulls back up around 65 feet to gain
speed
inflicting maximum pain on their enemy
to continue their bloodline
or die
they charge
colliding horns first
the equivalent of a head-on car crash
at 30 miles per hour
[Music]
armored skulls help cushion the impact
four-inch thick horn and three inches of
bone shield the brain
to absorb the shock
[Music]
even an armored skull can't hold out
forever
one of these headbangers is going down
[Music]
head bang after bone crushing headbang
for these muskox the fight for a harem
goes on
they collide with a force of almost one
ton
impact is so powerful it shunts through
the spinal column
vertebra five times bigger than a
human's helps soak up the strain
[Music]
between each soda can sized bone
three inches of cartilage that
compresses
absorbing the shock like a mini airbag
after 10 charges
the big chief is defeated
[Music]
he's escaped death
but at his age it's likely he's had his
last season of mating
he'll join a herd of other bachelors to
live out his days
for the raging bull
it was worth risking his life
he will continue his bloodline
and pass the baton
to the next generation
[Music]
for our next slippery contender
mating season is just beginning
[Music]
the coach whip snake
unlike other snakes coach whips get
going in the midday sun
they're active
and super aggressive
holy crap dude
it's spring
and this coach has one thing on his mind
he's on the lookout for a lady but
instead
he's slithering straight into trouble
hikers stumble across him
that's vicious
in a deadly fight with another male
coach with
the enemy has coach's head in his mouth
blood is pouring out
a coach whip is armed with razor sharp
teeth
four rows on their upper jaw
and two below
all point backwards to help draw prey
down the throat
these snakes don't kill their victim
they just eat it alive
coach doesn't want to be on the menu he
pulls an awesome move
oh my gosh the one that's being eaten is
now fighting the other ones in his body
clamping his jaws over the enemy's
windpipe
both trying to suffocate the other to
death
[Music]
coach loses his grip after a flip from
the enemy
suddenly both sense another danger
[Music]
with no external ears the coach whip has
poor hearing
instead it senses vibrations through the
ground
both snakes pick up the movement of
human bystanders
[Music]
distracted
they break free from each other
[Applause]
and race off into the scrub land
where the fight will continue
until one of them gets his girl
or dies trying
our next contender is one of the
mountain's most solitary creatures
one of three species of wild cat native
to north america
[Music]
meet
the lakes
their paws are three times the size of a
house cat
when they come face to face with another
lynx
the gloves are off
for no
rules hand to hand
come back
[Music]
the canadian wilderness
deep snow makes movement difficult
staying alive in the freezing
temperatures is even harder
this lone lynx is four times the size of
a house cat
he has a territory of 15 square miles to
hunt on
and will defend it with his all
he has a warm coat to survive the cold
long legs with big fluffy paws work like
snowshoes
enabling quick movement through deep
powder
perfect for hunting hares
the main part of his diet
he can spot a mouse at 250 feet
tufts of hair at the tips of his ears
enhance hearing by picking up the
smallest sound vibrations
[Music]
a terrifying sound makes a driver stop
his car
and start filming
[Music]
the lone lynx
has found a wanderer on his territory
with food scarce
he can't afford to lose land
paws hit like boxing gloves
they slam each other to the ground
the loner lashes out with a paw
the wanderer bites his claw
in return
changing tactics the loner flips on his
back
but this is not a move of submission he
now has all four sets of claws in the
air
so the wanderer can't get into attack
without risking his life
there's too much at stake to continue
with this strategic master stroke
the loner has won
the wanderer won't trespass here again
[Music]
in north america's towns and cities
one of the most surprising contenders in
animal fight night a small critter with
a big problem
and
a furious temper
cue
the shrew
an animal who must eat every three hours
or face death
so when shrews compete for food
they use tooth claw and deadly venom
to become suburbia's most savage
fighting machines
almost blind
shrews our prey for foxes
raccoons
dogs
and just about everything
against the odds
this old soldier has reached his first
birthday
but he can't hide forever
he has to come out and eat
every few hours
the shrew has one of the fastest
metabolic rates of all animals
to stay alive they must eat 90 percent
of their body weight every day or face
starvation
with such a high need for food
he simply can't afford to share
this guy will eat bugs
flies
and snails
if he finds another shrew on his patch
he'll eat him too
when this hungry trespasser drops in on
the old soldier's turf
it's blind rage
there's no taming this shrew
landing his target is tough
with poor eyesight shrews use smell
hearing
touch
and echolocation like dolphins and bats
shrews transmit and receive sound waves
to pinpoint their opponent's location
both shrew's strategy is to use their
front feet
to pin down the opponent
and strike with a vicious bite
their teeth deliver the ultimate weapon
venom
[Music]
delivered through grooves in the teeth
it can kill 200 mice with a single dose
[Music]
but neither shrew can land the killer
bite
[Applause]
the trespasser tries to get back in the
game
but once bitten
twice shy
this guy is done
he decides it's not worth his life and
hits the road
our old soldier
heads out for dinner
this battle may be won
but a shrew's war
is never over
found in america's southwest states our
next combatant
might look like a dragon from a
hollywood fantasy movie
but this scaly bad boy
is 100
non-fiction
one of only a handful of venomous
lizards in the world
with a split second bite and killer
sharp claws
this
is the gila monster
this gila monster is one of north
america's biggest lizards
he always goes it
alone and if there's one thing he hates
it's sharing
after a winter of hibernation it's high
noon
and time to eat
our lone ranger comes out of his burrow
only to find
there's a stranger in town
time for an ultimate lizard showdown
using any means necessary
to sink venomous teeth
straight to the head
a gila monster shootout
the lone ranger and the outlaw tried to
psych each other out
[Music]
the ranger makes a lightning draw
gila monsters can take in over three
times as much oxygen as other lizards
meaning that they can fight intensively
for longer
this is a mega monster match
with a bite as unrelenting as a bulldog
once they've got a grip they don't let
go
the ranger pulls a smackdown
the outlaw dazed
the ranger flips upside down
to deliver the knockout
unlike snakes gila monsters store venom
in their bottom jaw
pumping it through grooved teeth as they
chew enemy flesh
upside down gravity helps the venom flow
into the wound more quickly
only five drops of gila venom will kill
a dog in just 15 minutes
the outlaw is immune to the rangers
poison
but the bite still hurts like hell
enough to win the fight
and send the outlaw defeated
riding off into the sunset
but in america
[Music]
another bad boy bandit
[Music]
is never far away
[Music]
the neighborhood raccoon is an animal
with an unusual skill
with longer back legs than front
these guys are all about smarts
they can rotate hind feet to point
backwards
climbing down trees head first
if the branches hold up
this one-year-old raccoon has grown up
in the country
where raccoons share
and there's room for everyone
now like lots of raccoons he's heading
for town
where food seems plentiful
problem is
there are 20 times the number of
raccoons in american towns and cities
than in rural areas
so the country boy has some serious
competition
[Music]
city raccoons use their smarts to hustle
food
using a wide lower body and low center
of gravity to push over large objects
like trash cans
they have dexterous fingers
the area of their brain dedicated to the
sense of touch is among the greatest of
all known mammals
they soaked their paws to soften hard
skin
making them even more touch sensitive
[Music]
black bandit masks may enhance night
vision and help keep glare out of their
eyes
now the country boy has been eyeballed
in banded territory
this raccoon is ready to defend his food
snacks down
it's time for a smackdown
they size each other up
equally matched
this fight will be down to skill
country boy snaps
it doesn't faze the bear
nervous
the boy has second thoughts
but he hasn't eaten for days
this downtown throwdown
is about to get ugly
[Applause]
in this street fight
anything goes
raccoons fight mean and dirty
to unleash their killer move
the death shake
[Music]
for these raccoons there's a feast at
stake
fur flies
the country boy grabs the bandit by the
tail
as far from his mouth as possible to
avoid being bitten
bandit gets the boy down
time for the killer move
40 teeth including four sharp canines
clamp on to country boy's neck
with a move usually used to stun prey
the bandit tries to disorient the boy
with vicious shaking
time to take out the trash
and go in for the kill
the law shows up
a distraction
saving the country boy's skin
he gets away with it this time but this
boy's got a long way to go
to become a bandit of the burbs
[Music]
3
500 miles away
one of the largest wild animals in south
america
the
guanaco this continent's hardiest and
most adaptable fight night contenders
guanacos live all over south america
from patagonia
to peru
and they have the nastiest tactics of
all our fighters
going right for the family jewels
this six-year-old head honcho lives with
his harem of 10 females and their
offspring
on his 20-acre territory
[Music]
[Music]
female guanacos are fickle they want a
male who can keep them safe
keep them fed and father chulengos
baby guanacos
the head honcho can never relax
over half a million wild guanacos rome
south america
competition is rife
honcho's next threat looms on the
horizon
this four-year-old bachelor has hancho's
harem in his sights
the bachelor
charges
he swings his neck like a club but
misses
second time
poncho's not so lucky
the chase is on
there's only around 60 percent as much
oxygen as at sea level but guanacos can
run at incredible speeds of 40 miles per
hour
guanacos have adapted to live at high
altitudes
their heart is 15 larger than is usual
for mammals their size
a teaspoon of guanaco blood contains 68
million red blood cells
that carry oxygen around the body four
times that of a human
[Music]
the bachelor catches honcho
[Applause]
landing a powerful bite
the two front teeth and two canines are
called fighting teeth
they're sharp dagger-like
and guanaco's know just how to use them
they even try to bite off the other's
cojones
[Music]
but hancho doesn't want his avocados
turning to guacamole
so he heads for the hills
defeated
he's had his last tango with these girls
[Music]
while the bachelor has his pick of new
dance partners
this regular change of guard stops
inbreeding
the bachelor will become a puppy
and enjoy the family life
[Music]
for as long as he can hold on to it
brawls for the bloodline break out all
over the americas
[Music]
high summer
mating season for stellar sea lions
this big daddy rules the beach
all 25 females here are his to mate with
in return this rookery and the 20
nautical miles of ocean around it is
under his protection
perfect for sunbathing
playing
[Music]
and even some surfing
[Music]
but nothing lasts forever
big daddy has already fought off an
invading bull trying to take his place
[Applause]
and the next brutal challenge
is only a bloody wave away
[Music]
this sea lion cannot rest
he's so busy watching for rivals who
want to take his beach harem
the big daddy hasn't even eaten in a
month
[Music]
[Music]
an insurgent charges behind enemy lines
right onto daddy's beach it's a battle
of might
his flexible spine allows daddy to draw
back his neck
and inject maximum force into an 800
pound head slam
to win
one sea lion has to force the other down
the cliff
into the sea
big daddy gets high ground and leverage
to shunt the insurgent down the
cliffside
to help
a nasty bite
one inch canines designed not for
chewing
but for tearing flesh
[Music]
daddy inches the insurgent closer to
defeat
with one final push
bloodied and injured
the insurgent flees
big daddy has made it through another
mating season
time to get his strength up for next
year when the fighting starts over
for our next contender
it's all about that one girl
[Music]
in chile
juliet sits at the top of these trees
waiting for her romeo
at the bottom
romeo
he's a darwin beetle on the brink of
extinction as the world heats up
bigger than a baseball male darwins can
be three and a half inches long
[Music]
jaws make up almost half their length
and are used to attract the ladies
and dispatch the competition
romeo heads upwards
[Music]
meeting another beetle on the same
mission
[Music]
nothing
will keep this romeo
from his juliet
the rules of engagement use jaws to
reach over a rival's head and hook under
his wings
then lift and throw your enemy off the
tree
no problem for an insect who can lift
120 times his own body weight
romeo tries pulling the suitor off the
tree
but the rival holds tight
these fights can end in death
as one beetle rips the head from the
other's torso
romeo prize his opponent from the tree
[Music]
and throws him 80 feet to the ground
[Music]
with one of the hardest exoskeletons of
all insects
the fall is more annoying than fatal
for romeo
another challenger is right around the
corner
romeo wins again
and again
and again
finally he finds his juliet
after climbing 80 feet and battling many
suitors he's ready for his reward
and to do his part in keeping his kind
alive
but she's not so keen
he gives chase
[Music]
finally using his jaws to catch her
he continues his bloodline
his babies will be born and eat wood
found on the forest floor
so to save his partner the time of
climbing
he gives her a helping hand
what a guy
hopefully
there'll be many more high-wire darwin
beetles to come
[Music]
[Music]
you